[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRISANN BRENNAN:
I just wrote this.
It wasn't a part of my talk.
And I want to say that
I know a lot of people
have profound feelings
about Steve Jobs.
He was a gem and a rare one.
And I want to ask
you to please only
take what's of value of my
talk today and let the rest go.
This is such a new world to me.
So many people have
so many thoughts.
There's so many angles
of perception on him.
But today, I'm simply
talking about my perceptions.
And I hope you'll feel it's a
valuable contribution in total.
I also want to say
that I don't really
know the technical world
that you guys live in.
I don't know what he created.
So this is a new
experience for me.
And please forgive me for my
naivete at certain points.
So I'll begin.
Today, I wanted to talk about
creativity and initiative,
first mine in writing my book
and then Steve's in creativity
as I perceived it.
And thirdly, about
Creativity, with a capital C,
into the future.
Because whether we're talking
about children, new technology,
the arts, companies,
countries, or the whole world,
now more than ever we need to be
more conscious in our creating.
We're all so
creative that I think
we need a metalevel of
considerations, councils
even, to figure out
where we're going
and what we want
our outcomes to be.
Here I am at Google, and you
have the unofficial byline
of "don't be evil."
And this is what I'm talking
about, except more of it,
a long list of
ethical considerations
that people can cross-check
because everything
is affected by our creating.
Before I start
diving into my story,
I want you to know that I'm
predominantly right brained.
I wrote this book
cinemagraphically
because I'm first and
foremost an artist.
And the practices of filming
help me bridge my experience
as a painter into writing.
I think in a combination of
images, symbols, metaphors,
and words.
In fact, I don't
even think there's
a big difference between
symbols, images, metaphors,
and words because they're
as much an energetic fact
as this podium is for me.
Mainly, I think in
terms of energetics.
And I see energy and I
have found visualization
to be a force for actualisation.
This is one of my
most recent paintings.
It was commissioned.
And yet when I paint for someone
else, I also paint for myself.
The painting lay the
ground for my book.
This was my version
of an outline.
I didn't know what
it fully meant
until I was well
into the writing.
In fact, I'm still
discovering what it means.
I think the future is about
left and right brain integration
too.
Its the evolutionary next
step for people everywhere.
And it's, of course,
already started.
If I have time, which
I don't think I will,
I'll do a quick
decode on the painting
at the end of the talk.
And if I don't, I'll post
the image and a decode
on my book's website,
thebiteintheapple.com,
by the end of February.
So there were
three things that I
decided I would never
do in this life.
I had enough self-knowledge
by the time I was 35 years old
to know what I wasn't
interested or good at.
One was study of history.
I'd gotten crippling
migraines, at least
once a week, in my US history
classes when I was young.
I wasn't interested in so much
focus on men's wars, politics,
and treaties.
Number two is that I
would never play the drums
because my sense of rhythm
was so reliably wonky.
Number three is that
I'd never write a book,
since writing was
not my strength
and because I knew it was
way too much information
to organize and
be accountable to.
Yet here I've written a
book, and it's own history,
and it was in part due to
the rhythms in the language
that I became interested
in the craft of writing
for its own sake.
I'd written a couple of
good papers in art college.
But prior to writing
this book, that
was my only experience of
real concentrated writing.
Writing is traumatic
and stressful for me.
I love the ideas, but
they seem to bottleneck
if I have to sequence
them on a page.
Yet I decided I had to
write this book myself
because the process
of writing was
the only way I could drop
down into a depth of memory
and manage my own message.
I started in 2006.
And it took me over six years
of full-time work to complete.
Now I tell myself pay attention
to what I would never do,
because writing
this book has been
one of the most important
things I've ever done.
I also want to emphasize that
if I can write this book,
I'm really sure almost
anybody can do anything.
Over the years, a few people
had suggested I write my story.
Yet many more
warned me off of it,
even going so far to suggest
that I didn't have the right
to speak about my
life or my history
since it involved Steve Jobs.
And I think many people
were assuming the worst
and implying that it
was bad form for a woman
to speak about the
personal life of a man who
was a public figure.
But I did not write
this as a tell-all.
Instead, I felt my story was
important, one, because I knew
Steve before it all happened
and also because we came
of age together
in a certain way.
Two, because I witnessed
firsthand Steve's changes
as Apple began.
And three, because we
co-parented the child
through all the years.
Also four, I have
a universal message
and there's a universal
message in my book.
Steve and I met when we were 17.
And I was his first
love and I'm the mother
of his first child
and my only child.
We knew, loved, and
admired each other.
And when things got difficult
between us as Apple took off,
I witnessed his
incremental changes
from sweet, mystic, poet,
super-bright, goofy guy
into a ruthless, stunningly
successful business tycoon.
In the end, it is precisely
because of my direct experience
with him that I feel I have
important contributions
to make on the body
of knowledge with him.
And the other thing is I
never intended to pull him
from hero status.
I know so many people love him.
And it would've been
a balanced approach.
I was always more interested
in the human side of him.
Did I understand everything
that happened with Steve Jobs?
Absolutely not.
But I still think I
have an unusual vantage
point of some
things that I think
are unique and will be valued,
may be valued, will be valued.
So much seems to hang on
my memory, my integrity,
and my insight.
In 2006, I became sick
and it lasted for years.
I had one of those
undiagnosable illnesses
that probably came from a
combination of exhaustion,
mold in the apartment
I was living in,
and too much exposure
to fumes from painting.
With a compromised
immune system,
I got one terrible
illness after another
and had to spend a lot
of time doing nothing.
Bored and languishing,
I slowed way, way down
and became willing
to consider and then
to decide to write my story.
So with nothing else
to occupy my time
and in the most
tremulous, naive,
childish first
steps that I began
by writing a list of
chapters and some good ideas
in a cafe in
Tiburon, California.
To say I was reluctant
to be public about Steve
and my long history
is an understatement.
It's nuanced and
a difficult story.
And it was hard to sort through.
Also I didn't want
to relive the pain.
Of course, Steve didn't
want me to write it
and this was hard on me too,
mainly because it put pressure
on our daughter, who was going
back and forth between our two
households.
Additionally, for years I
absolutely questioned daily
if I had what it took
to write this book.
And I put it down
a couple of times,
only to return to it with
just greater commitment.
One because the
ideas were so rich,
that they just seem too
important, and also too
interesting to drop.
And two, because there
was this exquisite sense
of the pause in the writing
process that I loved.
The mounting silence of the
years coming up to the tipping
point and then their
remarkable fall into words.
I worked on the first
100 pages for two years,
trying to figure out how
to weave all the complexity
into something readable.
I worked seven days a week,
about two to three hours a day,
which took pretty much
all the energy I had.
When I started to get
physically better,
I committed to five hours
a day, seven days a week.
A huge turning point
came for me three years
into the project when a
colleague took my first 70
pages and turned them into
discrete, coherent chapters.
Once I understood how
to make a chapter,
I completed the next 19 chapters
in the second three years.
My daily experience
was that I would
wake up early every morning
and begin with the inspiration,
working out all kinds of ideas.
And yet no matter what,
by the end of every day
I was purely mortified
by what I had written.
This is a strange
and strained history.
The subject was
over the top and I
was deeply concerned
about how it
would affect our
daughter's life.
Also I felt that
my story is, was
a part of the
collective unconscious
and I feared no one
wanted to hear from me.
Add to this the fact that
I didn't know the writing
conventions for start talking
about such a dicey subject,
the personal and impersonal.
I don't read that much.
I had little experience
in communicating
about such difficulty
in a balanced,
truthful, and intelligent way.
Five years into my project,
I was still fretting
and I told a friend I needed
a Ph.D. to write this book.
And she said, well, Steve didn't
have a Ph.D. to do what he did.
So get over it.
Keep going.
People have assumed
I kept a journal
because the detail in the book
is so clear and descriptive.
But I didn't have a journal.
I'm just extremely
observant and I
seem to track detail
through all my senses.
Plus, this history
had somehow stayed
in something like a
morphic field around me
through the years
because I assume
it was waiting and pressing
on me to understand
what had happened.
As I said, the process of
writing was interesting to me.
And there were times that
things that seemed insignificant
buzzed at me to
explore more deeply.
And when I followed them,
they opened up my awareness
into new connections
and new revelations.
Other times after getting
the best sentences down
I could, I had to double and
triple check for the truth.
In going back and forth between
the descriptions and the truth,
further detail would emerge.
I found I also found that
using word combinations
of opposite meaning
helped me grasp
in language the
startling extremes that
were the hallmarks of Steve's
personality and charisma
after Apple started.
All in all, the craft
of writing itself
distracted me from
the pain, even
as I granulated down into it.
I have a type of dyslexia,
some kind of dyslexia.
And being that
that was the case,
I really could not
have written this book
with a pencil or
even a typewriter.
I don't think sequentially.
Much of the material
was so upsetting.
And yet with a
computer, it was all
made easier, as I was
able to move clusters
of ideas around it big swaths
to work out right connection
points, that opened up
more insight and balance.
The plasticity that the writing
with the computer provided me
was like painting and
it allowed for layering.
And so it made it
possible for me
to handle the many
years, while still
having fun exploring
the intricacies of ideas
I was trying to access,
layer, and get across.
Then after a while,
something unexpected
started happening, which
never would have occurred
if I had been so focused
on getting it right--
if I hadn't been so focused.
As I relived the scenes
in order to write them,
I became more of a
witness to it all
and started picking up
new levels of detail
that I had missed
when I had been
so young, living through it.
Plus the more attention
I brought to the history,
the more I saw and
the more I felt
that I was changing the
history inside myself.
Consciousness
changes everything.
For so long, I had met
Steve's ideas of things
define my reality.
And he had become defensive,
and fast, and intelligent,
and somewhat disconnected
from his heart
as he grew into Apple.
Out of this, he sometimes
projected the worst stuff
on me, faster than I
could process through it.
Yet as I slowed down and
focused on my experience,
I realize that things were not
as he had so deftly chalked
them up to be.
In a certain way, I had been
buried by Steve, the Zen
master, and the Apple-- or
the machine behind Apple.
But when I stepped
back into the history
to quietly tell myself my
story as I experienced it,
the "her" story of it all,
it was like waking up.
Spin is a powerful thing.
Interpretation is
a powerful thing.
But the truth is more powerful
within your own context.
A single voice does
make a difference.
We don't necessarily
hear ourselves
when others won't hear us.
But in writing, I
finally heard myself.
I also discovered
that forgiveness
is a process and a very
long haul, but a worthy one.
A line from an
ancient Hindu text
had replayed in
my mind for years.
It was a basic principle
of creativity, karmic law,
and life.
And it said, one must rise
by that by which one falls.
And here I found that by
doing the work of writing,
I was able to climb up and
out of my tremendous self-loss
into a lighter, truer being.
Throughout the writing,
as a discipline,
I cross-checked some of the
more complicated memories
with people who were also
there at certain points
in the history and
I got confirmations.
They had understood things as I
had, which was a great relief.
This, in addition to 10
years of visionary painting,
the six years of writing, and
I not only recovered my story,
I used the whole experience
to understand the history
through a wisdom and
compassion trajectory.
So that in essence,
the book provided me
the rare opportunity
to review my life
and take time to work
it out and update
it an ethical framework
for my 50-year-old self.
In the second 2/3
of the book, as I
lived how bad things
had been, I found
that I was traversing
what was for me how
realms of such destitute
feelings, that the only way
I remember true loveliness
was the little birds
singing outside my
windows in the morning.
The work was really
dramatic and extreme.
But on the other hand, the
terribleness had an upside.
It enlivened my sense
of determination.
Diving into the
dark and surfacing
is the artistic process.
And I'm no stranger to that.
I just had never done it
in words before and never
on the same subject for so long.
Long story short,
I dug my heels in
and decided I was going
to get my book written
or die doing it.
It was a messy process getting
into the do or die part,
but eventually I realized
that what I was really saying
was the opposite.
I was going to get
the book written
and live more fully
as a result of it.
Some people mistakenly think
I'm obsessed and fascinated
by Steve Jobs.
But this is not accurate.
I was obsessed by
getting at the truth
and fascinated by
my revelations.
It felt wonderful to speak, and
be funny, and open my heart,
and tell the truth.
It felt to me like I was
driving a little car over hill
and dale, looking
out the windows
and reflecting on the views.
I wanted to know why he
had been so cruel after we
had been so deeply in love.
I just kept staying
with the question
until I got the bigger answers.
I also wanted to put it
in its place and move on.
I did become more
interested and appreciative
of Steve's history,
but it was only
after I had renewed my
perceptions of myself.
As I mentioned before, I'd
been concerned all along
that my writing book this
would be hard on our daughter.
And the way that worked
is that the more I wrote,
the more I felt it was going
to be a bigger problem for her
and the world if the world
didn't have her mother's story
and if I didn't become strong
and clear enough to tell it.
I think that what
failed in Steve Jobs is
as important as what succeeded.
Both aspects should
be studied, partly
because he's so remarkable.
Well, because he's
so remarkable.
Also I know that a woman's
inner story may seem far less
exciting as a man's
worldly story.
In fact, for women it may be
that the inner story of a woman
is more interesting than
a man's worldly story.
But beyond all this, I want
my great-great-grandchildren,
should I be lucky
enough to have them,
know what a bit of their
grandmother's life and times,
as well as your grandfather's.
I think it will be
healthy and happy for them
because against all this dull
expectations, I feel Steve
and I were equals.
He simply had more power because
the laws favor men and money
over women and
children at this time.
I hope you don't mind me
being a little political.
The other thing that
truly inspired me to write
is that in many ways my story
is an all too familiar one.
Many women have had their own
experience with brilliant men.
And truthfully,
it's not just women
who are suffering
from the situation.
Obviously, it's a destructive
context for all of us.
The world is dealing with a huge
power imbalance, Wall Street,
corporate heads,
news corporations,
that sort of confuse
and drain people
in their personal
power, at least
that's the apparent reality.
So then I'd like to see
a genius bar working
to fix the brokenness
at this level.
Maybe we could call
it the ethics bar.
Eventually, I
started to figure out
that I could access the
highest integrity inside myself
by steering my writing
between truth and kindness.
If I could not say what
had to be said is kindness,
then I kept working to
understand more deeply.
If I could not tell the truth
because it was too terrible,
then I kept looking
for ways to say things
with more breath and allowance.
The extremes of negative
and positive relationship
in the adult Steve Jobs
and Chrisann Brennan
were and still are too
problematic to be public about.
And sometimes I was
thinking all the way
through the book about
Jung's "Red Book,"
the one he locked
up for 70 years
because he didn't
think people were
ready to take in the contents.
And I completely understand
his impulse to hold back.
Steve expanded the
spectrum in ways
that went beyond the
range of humanness.
And I mean that in both the
good and the difficult way.
And I finally figured out
I could approach the story
if I stayed in the middle.
Then I could
express enough truth
and that likely some
readers were even
going to be able to sense
the shapes of the things
I couldn't say.
Another exercise I
put myself through
was to pose the question,
if everything is love,
if this whole universe
is love, which
is what the mystics
support, and I
am willing to believe,
how do I understand love
in the context of what
happened between Steve and me?
Love is law and law
is based on love.
What happened was lawless.
Yet, I didn't want to make Steve
look like a spot monster that
was too big for me to handle.
And I didn't want to make
myself into a tiny speck
of a victim that
couldn't deal with it.
That would have
been way too easy.
I wanted to transcend
the polarization
and the lawlessness.
I wanted to find my power
in the center of it all.
I wanted a kind of
equanimity, a true equanimity.
I think that Steve was
a remarkable empath, who
became a colossal bully.
I'm sorry for those
of you who love him.
I think he was a liar, a
bully, a trickster, a thief.
And I think he was a sociopath.
Yet, he was also an honest,
remarkable, mystic, creator,
genius, visionary, who
wanted to see people freed up
through the tools he made.
What a cluster.
Another creative principle I
found in another Hindu text
says, divided into
two parts I create.
At first, I felt
blimied and even
lazy to parse through the polar
opposites, his polar opposites.
But then I became
very interested
in understanding the differences
between Steve's light and dark
sides because why else
should I write this book?
The independent
spirit in me always
got around to the
same conclusion.
I choose to be bigger than the
cruelty and the indifference.
I am going to tell
the truth and I'm
going to trust that I
have the tools to do it
without doing harm.
Moreover, I may end
up having to trust
the pieces to fly
and fall as they may.
But I'm willing to
wager that in the end,
the truth, told well
enough is a good thing.
I call my book "The
Bite in the Apple"
and not "out of the
Apple" because I
wanted to recover wholeness of
all that had been shattered.
There are two trees at the
beginning of the Bible.
One is the tree of
knowledge of good and evil
and the other is
the tree of life.
I wanted to put the
bite back in the apple
and become the tree of life.
No more talking snakes,
no more blaming woman
for the fall of man.
Writing this book was
my choice to return
to my original
spirit of wholeness
by way of my own work,
which was mine alone to do.
So now-- what time is it?
OK.
So now I want to talk
about Steve's creativity.
You all know more than I do,
as I said in the beginning,
about Steve Jobs'
accomplishments.
But I have probably
thought more about
how his early years
shaped his creativity.
I knew Steve was a genius
when I first met him.
Though if you ask
our daughter, she'll
complain that I think
everyone is a genius.
I hear her referring
to her mother's myths
and I think she worries
I've fed her pretty lies.
She is like Steve.
She likes to get
the facts straight.
But I absolutely know
what I'm talking about.
I do believe everyone
has genius in them.
One difference between
Steve and most other people
is that he figured out what
the work of his unique genius
was and he didn't allow himself
to be distracted from it.
He never gave up
and he never forgot
that there was
infinite potential
in a finite amount of time.
At the same time, I do feel
he lost some sweetness--
the sweetness of life in the
pursuit of all he accomplished.
The time in which
Steve and I came of age
was marked by disillusionment
with our parents' value system.
The '50s were filled with
the Cold War mentality,
superficial materialism as
the answer to a fulfilled life
and also the inauthenticity of
male and female role playing.
And we found ourselves rebels.
We were turning into rebels.
But we weren't rebels
without a cause.
In fact, we felt that we should
break the rules because they
were inadequate to
the sense that there
was something bigger to be had.
In 1983, I talked a writer
from "Time Magazine,"
who told me that when he
interviewed Steve Wozniak's
and Steve Jobs'
teachers in high school
after Apple had
started to succeed,
he said that they all
reported those years were
a rare time at the school
in every area of study
because kids were so
uncommonly creative and full
of self-authority.
That was that time.
Later, I spoke with
an attorney who
went to a Catholic
school in Santa Clara
at the same time Steve
and I were at Homestead.
And he told me that his
school was similarly
struck by some kind of fierce
originality, that came and went
within a period of something
like seven to 10 years.
Now I think what a
crazy alchemy, LSD,
Eastern mysticism, the
burgeoning technology of IBM,
the brute power of Lockheed,
all coming up at the same time,
creating new combinations
for re-envisioning design,
the value of aesthetics
in technology,
planetary interconnectedness,
and flower power.
I'm going to put this up.
This is another painting I did.
Now I'm going to tell
you a story that's
a part of Steve's past.
At first, it may
not seem to connect
to the theme of this
talk, creativity.
But you'll see why I
think it does shortly.
But first, take a
trip back to 1972.
The third time I met
Steve's mother Clara Jobs,
I was standing alone in the
living room waiting for Steve.
She came in and in an
urgent way began telling me
that they had adopted Steve, but
that the birth mother had taken
them to court because
she didn't want
her son raised by the Jobs.
In 1955, Joanne Schieble,
pregnant with Steve--
I actually don't know how
to pronounce her name.
My apologies-- had chosen a
family that was well educated,
wealthy, and Catholic,
for her baby.
But that couple decided
that they wanted a girl.
So the adoption
agency gave Steve
to Clara and Paul Jobs, who
had none of those qualities.
Clara told me that they
had to fight to keep him.
And then confessed
that she had been
terrified to love Steve for the
first six months of his life
for fear that they were going
to take him away from her.
At that, she just stared at me.
And I saw in her face a
deep, matter-of-fact guilt.
And then she told me
that even after they
had won the case, when
he was two years old
he was so difficult
a child to parent
that she wanted to give
him back to the agency.
And I think she may
have been trying
to indicate a root
cause to his cold side.
But that day I was
totally clueless
and would be for some
time because Steve
was very good to me.
Instead, I wondered why on
Earth my new boyfriend's mother
was telling me so much
personal information.
I was concerned about
her and wondered
in a simple
17-year-old way if they
did come to love
and cherish him.
Not long after that
conversation with his mother,
Steve started warning me too.
He told me on a number occasions
and in a number of ways,
he knew he was going to lose his
humanity in the business world
when he grew up.
I didn't know what
to think, starting
with was this something that
men knew and worried about?
I also wondered, how did he
know his future because I
had no sense for mine.
Back then, we were
just young lovers.
We moved in together
the summer before he
went to college,
an idyllic setting,
where we fell more in love.
Then he left for
Reed College and I
returned for my final
year of high school.
Late that fall, Steve
called and told me
he'd dropped out
of Reed, but was
staying in Oregon
to audit classes.
It's important to know here that
the crucial aspect in resolving
the court case with
Steve's birth mother
was that Paul and Clara
agreed to send him to college.
In fact, it was the most crucial
factor, maybe even the only,
in getting his biological mother
to leave him in their home.
But Steve was deeply
conflicted because he
was well aware of Paul's
anger and discomfort
about spending so much
money on his education.
Higher education wasn't a
part of the Jobs' experience
or value system.
Nor, apparently, was it to
keep their legal obligations
to the court and to the
birth mother of their son.
At 17, Paul and Clara
let Steve decide.
And he took things
into its own hands
and started auditing
courses that interested him.
I think it's instructive
to look at what
happened when Steve
dropped out of school.
Here we have a brilliant
prince of a genius integrating
the values of his
working class parents,
a guy who by any
standard should've
been given higher education.
But instead rerouted himself for
a different kind of emergence
into adulthood, so
as not too impinge
or be a burden on these people
whose feelings he cared about.
So there's three things I'm
getting from this-- that I've
thought about with this.
One, it seems to me that
the breach in the contract
was the beginning of a spiraling
out of right order in the sense
that it modeled the dropping
of right regard for Steve's
mother and the contract.
One might think it doesn't
matter because it was so long
ago and they had
put so much time in.
But dishonoring the mother and
the agreement in a court of law
set a pattern, or
it revealed one.
Two, if Paul and Clara had
been paying for the classes,
they would have
likely interfered,
or Steve would have
interfered with himself,
of Steve's being so playful
about his choices, dance,
calligraphy, and Shakespeare.
Reed College was after all
known for its math and sciences,
which is why it was
a good fit for Steve.
So the arts classes
would have seemed
anomalous to his obvious
intellectual talents.
Strike that.
I think-- anyway, strike that.
Three, after dropping
out of school,
Steve stumbled around
for a while and suffered.
Though he remained
sweet and positive
in his nature during
that searching time,
hitchhiking between the
Bay Area and Portland,
he was like a bird on the wire.
And there was a
deep rootlessness,
one might say
homelessness in him,
as he tried to
figure out what he
was going to do with his life.
I want you to know how
hard that was for him.
I was there.
I saw it.
It was painful.
He was deeply worried
about his life.
Also I was
disenchanted with him.
So I was not of much help.
But I don't think there
was anything anybody
could do for him.
He had to find his own way.
And yet he was
finding his own way
by looking at all
possible failure.
He knew there was something
that was supposed to happen.
Because just as he
had told me that he
was going to lose his humanity
in the business world,
he also told me that there was
something big that he was going
to do that would make
him famous and wealthy.
He didn't know what it was.
And I feel that it
was at that time
when he didn't know
what he was going to do
and feared he might
have missed it,
that I saw him become
mean spirited and stare
future down-- good Freudian
slip-- stare failure down.
And I feel this was the
beginning of his leadership
development.
Calamity, or rather the
flip side of calamity,
offers insight into
the creative process.
There is something about
how everything that gets
missed, gets tilled
under, and then
grows up into something greater.
This is a truism I think we
can all feel confidence in.
Like things don't get missed.
They go back under and find
other ways to come back up.
The irony, which is not the
best word for what happened,
is that even though he
did not go to school,
the personal computer
is the tool that
in the not so distant future
will enable a truly class world
education for every child
on Earth, affordably so.
The lesson, never underestimate
the power for failure.
It's a resource of immense
untapped potential,
because everybody keeps
trying to do things right.
The trauma of early
childhood, the abandonment
by both mothers in
the first six months,
probably had the most profound
effect on Steve's creativity.
In fact, I don't think there's
anything that ever happened
to him that he
didn't end up using.
So how might Steve's adoption
and the resulting attachment
disorder have affected his
extremely sensitive creator
self to make him a natural
part of the development
of a technology that
will connect the world?
In musing over this,
I leaped to the idea
that because Steve
did not know what
real connection
with a mother was
at such an important
developmental stage,
that he became a
part of inventing
a new kind of connection.
Trauma can cut people down.
But it could also
wake people up.
Some part of Steve
woke up when you
he separated from his birth
mother-- I mean I think so--
and after that, because his
adoptive mother didn't embrace
him for six months,
I think he was stuck,
mobilized, wired, and focused
to look for connection,
at the same time not understand
what he was looking for.
This is my personal
experience with him as well.
And when we consider how
technology is more and more
replacing face-to-face,
intimate contact,
I wonder if there isn't
something of his attachment
disorder built right into
the technology itself.
Before this amazing
techie world we exist in,
I was around to see how Woz and
Steve related to each other.
The two geniuses, three
years apart in age,
met regularly as friends
do and talked over
their most recent
ideas and discoveries.
I didn't know what
they were talking about
and I didn't care.
Instead, I loved
watching the acceleration
of their exchanges,
the bright, happy flow,
the shock of the new.
They seemed to be very
animated, jump up and down,
talk over and around each
other, in Paul's garage
and other places too.
It was like a duet
of a great affection.
Sometimes they could barely get
their words out fast enough,
finishing each other's
sentences and laughing
to acknowledge all
that did not need
to be said, because
as Steve might say,
insanely great
minds think alike.
Yet as true as that
was, sometimes it
went over the edge
for me because there
was something else going on.
I'd forgotten about this other
thing until I started writing.
Their speech patterns could
be so rapid fire, their tones
so shrill, that it
was as disturbing
as fingernails on a blackboard.
And I'm not exaggerating.
It was awful.
When the memory
of this weirdness
came back to me when
I was writing my book,
it occurred to me that something
about how they were relating
may well have been the
beginning of what would later
be coined the "reality
distortion field" because it
felt like something being
torn out of coherence.
As I say, it wasn't always
this way, but just at those
times when the sounds
were so unbearable
that I'd get myself
out of hearing range.
Often I'd sit in the living
room at the Jobs's and wait
for it to be over.
And I did not ask myself why
or what it was, but I do now.
I think the technology has a
double edge of both connecting
and disconnecting people to
and from each other, Steve
and Steve, with a
double edged sword that
connected and disconnected
things at the same time.
Do we know what they were doing?
Do they know what
they were doing?
I think we need to be
more conscious and intense
about asking what the technology
is doing to us, biologically,
emotionally, intellectually,
and spiritually, creating
a serious, serious business.
Many people who came of age
before the personal computer
can remember such an
extraordinary sense of beauty
and potential in the
air in the '60s and '70s
and wonder what happened
to all that promise.
Anybody, like over 50,
might remember this.
You can ask them.
They may have this memory.
Did something truly
over the top remarkable
open up and then fail
in some important way
to fulfill itself?
I live in Monterrey
County right now.
In the romantic history of
Cannery Row and Steinbeck,
there came a time
when there were
no more sardines in the sea.
The industry was fished
out and had closed down.
And all the people who
make their livelihoods off
that industry were
greatly alarmed
and asked where did
the sardines go?
It was as if they were looking
into the wine-dark sea,
unable to see the
bleeding obvious.
The answer came by way of
one Ed Ricketts, a scientist,
a philosopher, a early
ecologist, and a friend
of Steinbeck, Henry Miller,
and Joseph Campbell.
He was a remarkable
guy by all accounts.
And he simply said,
"they're in the cans."
I believe the
extraordinary vision
that so many felt
in the '60s and '70s
got absorbed into the computer
age, a kind of can if you will,
so much mental, an
intricate kind of can.
And now I know I'm
singing to the choir.
I perceive I'm
So I'll just continue.
I believe that we
need new visions now.
We upped the game
with the computer.
But I think it's taken up too
much space in our imaginations,
to the point of flattening them.
There's too much focus
on screens, on function,
and on transaction.
I feel we need to swing back
to free up our imaginations
for new kinds of questions,
more balanced, with greater
attention to
integrity and nature
and value of face-to-face
intimacy of our humanness.
I think a lot of people
are haunted by Steve.
His creativity was
so over the top
that I hear many
question with anguish,
what would Steve Jobs have done?
What would he have gone on to
create had he lived longer.
And I want to say, I don't think
this is the right question.
His death is really sad.
And he boggled the
imagination of so many
around the whole world.
And yet if we want to show
appreciation for all he did,
why not take the
best of his example
as inspiration to ask new kinds
of questions of one's self,
for new kinds of frontiers?
He was a unique contributor.
And he got a remarkable
ball up into the air.
Yet I think we need other
kinds of balls in air now too.
A good question is a
very powerful thing.
Once it's been asked,
the genius inside,
the person who asked it of
themself, or heard it asked,
will work day and
night, through their
conscious and
unconscious, to answer it.
I mean if Jesus said of
his own remarkable life,
"this and more
shall you do," then
I think we have a directive to
be mindful and imaginative--
why are we imaginative about
the truth of everyone's
creative capacity,
not just potential,
but a person's
individual imperative.
I think people are
haunted by Steve Jobs
not quite because of
what he accomplished.
But because he tapped into a
level of creativity in himself
in such a significant
way that it suggests
this too is possible.
This is where it's haunted.
I believe his
creativity is at least
as great as the
computer, at least.
Steve Jobs was enlightened.
He was what enlightenment looks
like in a business context.
And yet because he never
received the love of a mother
when he was so young,
he was an example
of harnessing an awakened
state without being emotionally
integrated.
This is quite a combination.
And though he
didn't do so badly,
it does give us a clue
into why he did not
spearhead a new
level of ecological
and compassionate best business
practices around the world
when he, of all
people, was so inspired
and in a position to do so.
One of the pillars of
enlightenment is self love.
And I think that bereft of
the real heart connection
with both mothers
when it mattered,
that Steve just kept building
wealth to compensate.
I'm not looking for blame.
But I'm thinking more in
terms of an agreed upon course
correction into the
future of technology.
My impression is
that the technology
needs to be redesigned so that
it works more harmoniously
with the human energy system.
I don't mean ergonomics.
I'm talking about
the development
of the harmonics
of the technology
for the full dimension
of our humanness.
We all know a day
spent on the computer
can give us a feeling
of a day lost,
or I think we feel that way--
I'm talking for everybody--
somehow gone unlived,
even if we got a lot done.
There's an emptiness and
an emotional flatness.
It's as if we're making
new forms all the time
and the brilliance
is uncontestable.
But are we evolving
and enriching
our humanness and
human experience?
For example, here's an idea.
And I'm almost finished.
Consider the cell phone
as the new cigarette.
Its energy is gray and graying.
People go off by
themselves to use it.
They reach for it
unthinkingly as a distraction,
with the same regularity.
It's addictive and it lights up.
So here we have an
example of wanting
to connect while the behavior
actually blocks connection.
In my imagination, I think that
a company, one at the cutting
edge of the market into
the future of technology,
they'd hire an unusual
kind of workforce
to start figuring out how
to make the technology
work with our biological,
emotional, intellectual,
and spiritual constitutions.
OK, two more paragraphs.
Our machines are cool.
And thanks to Steve's exquisite
sensibility and insistence,
they are more
beautiful than ever.
But I think we
are too impressed.
They're supposed to serve us.
We should not be
serving them-- we
should not serve them,
nor pattern after them,
nor be entrained by them.
The technology is powerful.
But the discernment
is that it's only
as good as the person
who uses it being
responsible to their
own unique heart vision.
And so I want to read something
from my Henry Miller days.
a quote.
And since he wasn't
just a little sexist,
I've changed a few pronouns.
We live in a different time now.
He said, every day we
slaughter our finest impulses.
That's why we get
a heartache when
we read those lines written
by the hand of a master
and recognize them as our own,
as the tender shoots which
we stifled because
we lacked the faith
to believe in our own powers
and our own criteria of truth
and beauty.
Every man and woman,
when she gets quiet
and when she becomes
desperately honest with herself,
is capable of uttering
profound truths.
We all derive from
the same source.
There's no mystery about
the origin of things.
We are all part of creation,
all royalty, all poets,
all musicians.
We have only to open up and
discover what's in here.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: I want to revisit
some of what you shared,
both at the end and about your
process in writing this book.
And in particular--
so within Google
we're a company
creating software
that people are using,
even in particular around
like authoring.
So I'm curious, given
some of the things
that you had highlighted about
sort a greater, like a greater
connection to our humanity in
terms of how we use computers
for expression, for authoring,
and some of the things that you
had mentioned early on
around approaching the book
and writing cinematically, and
a lot of the reflection that
took place for you
around steering
this kind of middle course
between extremes, I'm curious,
do you see like ways
that tools could
be improved to support the kind
of authoring-- to support you
in the processes
you went through
for like another
kind of expression?
CHRISANN BRENNAN: I
feel-- this is out there--
but I feel it needs to be bumped
up to a whole other level.
Now, is all this function.
I mean that's another
good question.
And it's going to ring
through me because there's
no way I can quite answer that.
And also I'm tremendously
grateful for the tools that
are because it was remarkable
what I was able to do.
I don't have an idea--
my biggest idea is
that the energetics
of the computer
needs to be a higher frequency
so that it's not cutting off--
OK, so this is what I think.
I think the computer is cutting
people off from their hearts.
I think it's cutting
them off from maybe
even the reason they came here.
If it's cutting off their
hearts and their hearts
have the reasons they came
here, like their own destiny.
So what I would like to see
just a gifted workforce who
can come in and who
know multiple levels
of possibilities and can
design consciousness.
It's weird.
Because I don't really want
computers to be babies,
like new life forms.
But still, I would
like the computers--
I know that there are
people-- and some of you
could easily, probably
have that in you.
It's a calling.
It's something that you're
not-- only by magic and accident
do you get trained for.
So in terms of the functionality
of how the computer can help
remarkable people be more
creative, I have no comment.
I feel like the design of the
machine itself needs to be-- I
don't even know
what words-- redone.
AUDIENCE: Maybe transformed.
CHRISANN BRENNAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: To pick up on some
of the themes you mentioned--
I mean I appreciated the analogy
you gave around like a cell
phone as the kind of
like modern cigarette.
When you're standing
in line, it's
a way to sort of pass the time.
CHRISANN BRENNAN:
Good, good one.
I should add that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And it's somewhat ironic because
it's a device for communication
and we use it for like
disconnection, a disconnection
from ourselves, a disconnection
from the people around us.
In terms of some of
what you had just
been mentioning, the way that
computers and technology is
conceptualized
right now, it's very
much around kind of
spectacle and sort
of what we see,
seeing new things.
And it sounds like
I was hearing you
get at how there may be
possibilities around supporting
a kind of reflection
or introspection,
like arriving at insights
kind of internally.
I'm curious if that's
something that you're also
envisioning as a
possibility there
CHRISANN BRENNAN: Well,
it's an interesting thing.
I mean the furthest I've gone
with it is that people need
time to be reflective with
the human energy system.
It's already so much-- it's
light years ahead of anything
we can do with the computer.
So in terms of
using the computer,
I think it's a problem.
That's exactly where
the problem is--
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CHRISANN BRENNAN: --eclipsed.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
CHRISANN BRENNAN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for coming.
AUDIENCE: Thanks
for coming also.
CHRISANN BRENNAN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]